is it garbage if the florida side of
your family's biggest christmas eve
tradition is sloppy joes
[Applause]
dude that's the saddest [ __ ] i ever
heard
father
will santa claus bring us more chili
dogs this year
father
dude
i ain't gonna lie i'm [ __ ] down with
a sloppy joe
and if it did so happen to be christmas
and it was a [ __ ] fresh crock pot
full of them and a couple of [ __ ]
potato buns
i'd get into the holiday spirit as they
say
and making homemade or is it manwich
all right let's not [ __ ] get all
humbly
he's actually
it's actually homemade all right
beautiful wait who makes it
we switch off every year of course oh
that's real trashy yeah
who doesn't have it there's no quality
control on that
that's not a tradition
it dates back
stop i i heard they ate it on the
mayflower i swear
the nina the pint and the sloppy joe
everybody knows that
we still got the boat in the garage i
sort of [ __ ] got i'm telling you
right now
fit dude that's crazy this guy's
dropping fifth generations
well i didn't think they were the
kennedys
[Applause]
they were so poor
i just thought they were rich people
having fun you know what should we have
tonight the goose no the tater tots
let's have the tater tot casserole
instead oh that's great that's a [ __ ]
home run of a question clap it up
i told you tampa came to [ __ ] play
baby and yeah i i say it is trash but
they're probably [ __ ] fantastic and a
couple of those in a glass of [ __ ]
ice cold milk would [ __ ] knock me the
[ __ ] out
so i'm up here talking [ __ ] but i'll see
you around the holidays is what i'm
pretty much saying
uh where's matthew c at
uh what's up brother how are you the
jack dude we saw on the yeah it's all in
the parking lot it's awesome these guys
all [ __ ] yoked up dudes what's all
pro sex you're coming to tampa i'm like
all right [ __ ]
regretting tampa already
you look like a power ranger you get off
you really do man
especially down here you got the [ __ ]
look and everything yeah
he's killing it who are you here with
buddy
[Music]
your old roommate what happened there
i've never heard anybody say is my
that's a friend then
yeah
[Laughter]
old roommate some [ __ ] went down over
the cable bill for sure
we used to be in business together
still waiting on the courts to settle it
oh man this will
you look good but
only on the outside
you're going to get booed in a second
so before that happens thanks for coming
buddy yeah
if i don't see you after the melee
thanks
no uh does reusing the same razor for a
year at a time because you don't want to
pay for a new one make you garbage
[Applause]
[Music]
and test positive for hepatitis i
believe
dude what are we doing civil war soldier
what the [ __ ]
is it a disposable razor
oh what
dude you can't even buy just one of them
they come in packs of like 30.
i'm good for the next 50 years
dude holy [ __ ] no wonder why their buddy
moved out
okay you come out your [ __ ] face all
sliced up every morning
hey wanna get some breakfast nah i'm
good i'm all right
i'm late
bleeding in your cereal and [ __ ]
why what you just
oh the roommates
okay
now we're [ __ ] getting down to it
i knew it was deeper than i got a new
job
we thought you were over it but now
grudges stay long so you don't have a
lot of facial hair is what you're saying
well like one a year man what are you
how often are you crazy i don't care if
you're a baby
so you use a disposal razor 100 times a
year
dude that's recommended use three times
ladies and gentlemen three times doctor
recommend the use of a disposable razor
holy [ __ ] dude
uh clap clap clap it up for matthew
that's gonna haunt me in the i'm gonna
be [ __ ] thinking about that for weeks
dude every time i shave for the rest of
my life i'm like that [ __ ] crazy
bastard of them
and clapping up as a boy for sneaking
that cheap shot in when he's down too
cause he can't grow hair yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] huge [ __ ]
and he ate my cereal